is Mr Beast a disgusting exploitive
monster or is he a hero are both of
those arguments have been flying around
the internet for over a day now and
that's because over the weekend he
uploaded a video titled 1 000 blind
people see for the first time we see him
work with a surgeon to perform an
operation on blind and partially blind
people that would allow them to get
their Vision back they can't see but we
have all the technology to fix it yep
half of all the blindness in the world
is people who need a 10-minute surgery
but the thing is a lot of these people
just don't have access to it or the
money for it even though it's
life-changing with a number of people
sharing their stories to Mr Beast and
his team you know one person in the
video saying blindness stop them from
working another saying he's never been
able to drive a car but this procedure
changed all that and of course because
it's Mr B's he didn't just stop at the
surgeries he gave one guy a Tesla others
got money what does this say
[Music]
you just won ten thousand dollars here
you go oh my gosh y'all see him take
this International with people from
other countries also getting help and in
total changing at least a thousand lives
and largely the response to this video
has been very very positive people
saying it's heartwarming it's amazing
but also others saying things like are
we going to start celebrating people
with resources giving back to people for
entertainment only he gave these
surgeries to people who agreed to be in
a YouTube video for him to monetize how
is that charity and he just makes people
dance on camera for basic human needs so
we can make millions as well as some
that were split saying he makes a good
impact but he does it in a borderline or
maybe not borderline unethical way that
benefits himself more than anyone he
could ever help giving should be a
selfless act well here was some of the
online discourse courtesy of distractify
to give you a little bit of flavor of
what people were saying quote if Mr
Beast truly wanted to do something good
and truly cares about disabled people he
would not monetize their suffering and
make them tap dance on video just so he
can slap it up on YouTube I'm tired of
having to perform gratitude for wealthy
people just us to stay alive others went
even further this person tweeted there
is something so demonic about this and I
can't even articulate what it is and
they've got screenshots from the video
sticking with the satanic theme here
this individual really went all in
tweeting he is literally the Antichrist
there's always some sick people okay
so what do you think about people being
mad about this okay
I've been start from the beginning I
don't like when people film people
giving to homeless people
that don't matter you know it's not a
machine camera whatever
so you walk in the world then you always
look sharp go ahead a sport you good
it's fine
stop getting like a school girl because
I said something nice that's fine and
I'm not gonna find it it's so [__] up
to have a beard wait this is a selfless
ax I just did for you on camera which
we're gonna monetize you're a [__]
demon I'm the Antichrist he didn't even
see that coming
I would not have done that kind of thing
on camera or a demon hey I'll say this
people get mad because they film the
stories
take the macro aspect out of it this is
your sibling your sister your brother
your father doesn't matter they've not
been able to see for most of their life
and they can't afford to fix it and you
can't afford to pay for it and Mr Beast
comes by and he says listen
I think I can help
I can give your father his eyesight so
he can look at you again
and he gives you an option he says we
can tell your story or we cannot because
understand there's a thousand people
that they've helped they didn't film all
those stores there's plenty of people
they helped that would never went online
and they gave people options would you
like to tell this story and you say I'd
love to if this helps you make more so
you can help more people I would love to
If this means that you raise awareness
for the fact that most people are blind
not due to some genetic issue that can't
be cured but because of easily curable
10-minute procedures that we can't
afford I would love to and all of a
sudden your father can now see again
they're they're bawling their eyes out
because they're making eye contact and
they really feel like they're being seen
for the first time that's what he's
giving these people
and rather than having this kind of
outrage for the systems that create
these inequalities you directed at the
individual who's greatly improving their
lives and allowing families to be able
to look at each other
there's not a day that I'm ever going to
look at somebody doing some this
positive and try to figure out their
motives I don't even care let's say I'm
the most uncharitable person and I think
Mr Beast is a selfish piece of [__]
human being who's only doing this for
the clicks I don't give a [__] that's
how there is a thousand people now that
can see that couldn't see yesterday and
if he takes that money it wants to be
more egotistical to save another
thousand I will celebrate that too I
don't give a [__] what's in this heart
or what his intentions are people that
couldn't see can now see that's a way to
be egotistical do you understand
close your [__] eyes now that's your
rest of your life someone can change
that I will never sit here
and get mad at him for that that that's
because we spent too much time in our
society celebrating [__] with guns
shooting each other celebrating people
who are getting violating the ring or
doing other kinds of crazy stuff
someone's giving people their eyesight
back bring it and you want to call them
demons tell them then [__] I want to be
in hell
especially now it's kind of cold outside
I'm just keeping this stacked with y'all
this is the kind of stuff that I see
people doing online that I'm like this
is Goofy virtue signaling to me yo think
about the outcomes that's just I want
you guys to think more but you said
something very interesting
that's how we choose to be selfish
like if he wants to think about what
you're saying guys
his way of being selfish
like he loved he loves clicks so much
that he's going to be selfish and help a
thousand people
I think the word selfish has such a
negative connotation because I think the
way that people employ it is like
there's an extreme interest in oneself I
think most actions if you take it at the
little definition have some
self-interest involved man when you do
something good for other people you
partially do it because it feels good
because you're rewarded because you're
strengthening bonds because you're
helping others yeah you're doing it for
them but there's also a part of you
that's rewarded for that that's not even
a bad thing this is literally our
biology all right and our social skills
being programmed into us to encourage us
and incentivize us to do good things the
same thing with our families and helping
them like it does give us a rewarding
feeling
and it's okay you don't have to feel
guilty about that it's not a bad thing
this is our social engineering over
hundreds of decades encouraging us to
create communities whether you're giving
people tax write-offs so they can donate
more whether you are telling people
you're a great job and I really
appreciate and you're making them feel
good when they do something good
whatever the [__] it is encourage people
to do good we need to we need to
encourage everybody to start giving more
to do more because it helps the people
in your community and I'm not even
talking about big stuff go volunteer at
a soup kitchen and I'll say good I'm
grateful that you're doing that even if
you only doing it to hear my words of
affirmation it doesn't [__] matter
because they need those volunteers you
understand so whoever it is if they do
something good go out of your way to
thank them to really appreciate what
they've done show gratitude because it
might just be the extra boost that they
need to do more good for other people
and guess what you're creating a chain
reaction so let's get out of trying to
read people's intentions to try to make
people perfect enjoy those that don't
exist who are Mother Teresa
right and let's just encourage people
when they do something good that's all
um I'm not a fan of people giving to the
like to homeless people like a 20 bucks
and you're like
camera in the face it's [__] up
and I think it's a different thing than
what Mr Beast does just because
you're filming Misery all right these
people are not honestly miserable but
like I feel like sometimes they don't
they they don't get asked those homeless
people if they want to be on cam you
just happen he arrived here with your
cam and you give that that that [__] I
hate like ask people if you you you want
to film them and stuff like that in the
case of Mr Beef and the case of Mr Beast
Mr Beef not that he came home with them
Burgers I might start calling them Mr
Beef
hey pause Mr B sounds like a good porn
me you found out this league is hung
yeah hey Mr Beast went to Mr Beef yeah
and then when he come he said he goes ah
what because he is the icing on the cake
anyways let's go let's go back yeah so I
don't like when they do that now in this
case with uh Mr Beast himself
he guests people on there he asked him
to be like there's a consent to be there
and he heals them
and yet the reason why he's able to do
that to so many people is
because people are watching his video so
it goes back so he did he create a
separate Channel called uh Mr B's
philanthropy right so he did a separate
thing
to be able to help people and give back
because at some point you get so much so
much out of you and you you cover your
basic needs you want to give back it's
either two things okay uh when you you
stack up a lot of money it's either you
buy stupid [__] or you give back
it's really the two avenues that you
have so he decided to create another
like a separate channel to give back to
people and whenever he does that in the
process that he he does that of course
it's going to be he's gonna make a video
out of it to make more profit to be able
to give back to other people so it's
like if those people that cannot give
back to other people are actually with
those videos helping give back to other
people I don't know if you understand
what I'm saying right they give to the
next person
so if Mr B's helped me I help Mr Beast
Mr B Subs uh some some other person so I
don't think it's that bad and I don't I
really don't think it is the same thing
as people just arriving in front of uh
homeless people not care because when
you're a radical homeless people and you
don't ask them permission you do not
care about the situation when we are
it's not the same level yeah but I'm
helping you so shut the [__] up and you
don't have to you don't have the right
to say yes or no these people have the
right to say yes or no you know what I
mean so yeah I can understand the
feeling when people say that uh uh he is
using those people but you hear all
those people say well you know it only
takes two billion dollars to to solve
World anger grow anger we're a hunger
and people don't think and people don't
do it and people don't do it on stuff
they don't do anything Elon Musk right
you you hear all sorts of things about
people with a lot of money that they
don't do nothing with their money and
then you see someone that does actually
something good with his money
you know how many YouTubers that are out
there that do stupid [__] with their
money
that go out and create more videos to
create more stupid [__] I rather like
this you can call it what you want but
I'd rather I'd rather this so I'm with
it
it's a bit like uh like what Kat
Williams said
I don't eat [__] for you I eat for me
does it make you feel good yeah but I
didn't do it for you I heard it for me
and there's another thing that I was
just thinking while Abba was talking
maybe he does that for clips for maybe
he does that for clicks Maybe
maybe he films the whole
Fortress
or for awareness so you show where it
goes
so you show where the money is taken and
where it goes and how the process was so
you don't think it's a sham to get more
clicks actually no like a lot of things
that happen and a lot of other uh
fundraisings that happened that we
didn't know where the money is going
that's the proof that people
are being like
beefy you know they're being freed for
the cycle from from their shackles of
blindness you know what I mean you can
actually see the work where he goes What
It Takes and it brings awareness to what
this thing is it's really simple you
just need this boom that's it maybe it's
just awareness and transparency I I
don't believe I don't know I don't
believe half the people who have an
issue with this really care about the
issue I think when someone's popular and
they're doing a good thing they're
trying to people want to see the demons
yeah why because they become very
uncomfortable
with the thought of someone being really
good in that sense because it reflects
their own negative Impressions about
themselves and it shines a light on what
little that they're doing but you don't
have to be insecure it's not because
someone else is shining bright that
there's something that you have to be
feeling terrible about
their light doesn't have to dim yours at
the end of the day I'm just happy that a
lot of people get to see you know that's
a beautiful thing it's a beautiful thing
if you've ever had short periods of time
where you didn't have access to your
vision you know how [__] chilling
that is and some people have to live
with that every day and they cope and
they adjust and they make life work
but for those who do get that gift it's
a beautiful thing when I see people who
would otherwise be bound to wheelchairs
their whole lives get Prosthetics that
are newly built technology I'm excited
for them people are getting a better
life
you know and with all the negative stuff
happening in the world it's cool to see
the technology and these creators who
are you know are high school dropouts
all the time or or are pooling their
resources together to create change in
the lives of so many [__] people
so I don't know to me I didn't want to
just end this getting mad at the
detractors what he did was [__]
amazing
period amazing if I could reach if I
could reach as many as many people as he
can reach and do as much good [__] yeah
I mean listen you know we got people who
like glorify their lives with
possessions and Bugattis and whatever
the [__] else they can afford everyone's
like wow that's the Pinnacle of success
nah bro this is what it is when you can
change communities change their lives of
so many people for the better using your
hard-earned dollars not for your
self-interest but for changing other
people's lives
to me uh yeah I know it's just I think
it's a beautiful thing and you're gonna
have a hard time convincing me otherwise
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you